we continue wayne newton week here on  good day  when chatting with him one-on-one i had  a chance to ask him what his favorite  moment on stage has been and certainly  that's a tough question considering his  extensive career but he has one many of  you may remember it he helped open  t-mobile arena a few years ago with rock  band the killers take a listen  i decided to close my segment  with my way  and i didn't say anything about frank  sinatra in the whole  lineup of songs  and i started singing it and as i did  everybody in the audience  took out their phones and turned on the  lights  you know and it was the most beautiful  sight i actually got teared up  because i thought  i know he's up there watching and he  should be proud of this moment  he has some good frank sinatra stories  as well so stay tuned for that